this vote means that now the
full senate can start debating the
infrastructure package formally
so far only a handful of
senators were negotiating it
privately altogether this bill would
spend a trillion dollars
repairing deteriorating roads and
rail around the
country and would also invest in
public transportation and expanding
fast and secure internet access in
rural areas legislators still
face a lot of work to negotiate
the details of this proposal and
ensure that it accumulates the necessary 60 votes
in the Senate to become a
reality  bailén's president and
Democrat leaders also wanted to pass a
second $3.5 trillion plan
on what they call
human infrastructure
that plan would invest in healthcare,
clean energy and education
Democrats hoped to pass this
plan with only the support of the 50
Democrats in the Senate but the
democrat senator kyrsten sinema of arizona
expressed her support for
the plan now the democrats will have to
negotiate that plan among themselves with
senator cinemas if they want to
hope to pass it reporting in
washington
alexandra limon